[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Welcome back.
I hope you had a
good Thanksgiving
and all refreshed
and ready to think
about some theory
of computation.
We're in the homestretch now.
We have this lecture
and two more to go.
And so today, I have for you,
a completion of the theorem
we started before the
break, where we introduced
probabilistic computation and
we talked about the class BPP,
as I hope you remember, and
we looked, in particular,
at these problems involving
branching programs, where
we started the proof that the
problem of equivalence of two
read-once branching programs
can be solved in this class BPP.
So what I'm going to do is
spend the first 15 minutes
or so just reviewing where we
were, because we started this,
it feels like a
long time ago now.
And I just want to make
sure that you're all
on the same page and we're all
remembering what we were doing.
And then, I will
finish off the proof.
And along with doing
that, we're going
to introduce an
important method.
Well, we started that.
We looked at the method of
arithmetization last time.
So we'll review that.
We're going to use
that again in the work
that we're going to start on
Thursday on interactive proof
systems.
So this is a kind
of, in some ways,
both an interesting theorem in
its own right, and a warm up
for what we're going to
be doing in the last topic
of the semester.
OK.
So let's just remember
what we were doing.
So we introduced
probabilistic Turing machines.
So those are these
machines that have--
a kind of
non-deterministic machine,
but there's a different
rule for acceptance.
And these are also
non-deterministic machines
which can either
make one choice, just
to have a deterministic
move at a step,
or they can make two choices.
And when the machine
makes two choices,
we actually think of there
being a probability there,
where the machine
is tossing a coin
to decide which branch to go on.
So with that, there is a
tree of possible branches.
And the probability of
some particular branch
is going to be 1 over
2 to the number of coin
tosses on that branch.
And so we then use that
to define the probability
that the machine
accepts, which is
the sum over all of
the probabilities
of the accepting branches.
And the probability
that it rejects
is 1 minus the probability
that it accepts.
So thinking about it--
this captures the
idea that if you just
run the machine on a random set
of inputs from the coin tosses,
what the probability that
you're going to end up
with the machine accepting.
That's the probability
of acceptance,
defined in that way.
Now, if we're thinking
about the machine deciding
some particular
language, it's supposed
to accept the strings
in the language
and reject the strings which
are not in the language.
But because of the probabilistic
nature of the machine,
it might get the wrong
answer on some branches.
And so we say that
a machine decides
a language with a certain
error probability,
means that the probability
of getting the wrong answer
is going to be, at most,
that error probability
epsilon over all of the
possible inputs to the machine.
So if we say that the machine
is error probability 1/3
that means that it gets the
right answer for every string
with probability at least 2/3.
OK, so that led us to the
definition of this complexity
class BPP, which I don't
even remember if I told you
what it stands for.
It's bounded probabilistic
polynomial time.
That's what BPP stands for.
The "bounded" means is
bounded away from 1/2
because we don't want
to allow the machine
to have probability 1/2,
because then bad things happen.
The machine can just
toss a coin when
it decides to make
an answer, and not
really give us any information.
Then, we also went over
the amplification lemma.
We did not give
the proof, but we
went over the statement
of the theorem.
The proof is really
just a calculation
that you can drive down that
error probability to something
extremely tiny just by
basically repeating the machine
and taking the majority
vote of what it
does on several different runs.
If you run the machine
100 times and you
see if it's mostly accepting,
then you want to accept.
And the chances that the
machine was really biased
toward rejecting,
even though you're
in your sample see mostly
acceptance, is extremely small.
And you can calculate that, but
you can make that very tiny.
So small that, for all
practical purposes,
it's really giving
you the right answer.
But it's not deterministic.
So it's not quite
100% guaranteed.
And the way I like
to think about BPP
in terms of the computation
tree of the machine,
so that when it's accepting,
most of the branches
are accepting, weighted by
their probability, of course.
So the there are many accepting
branches when you're accepting,
and many rejecting branches
when you're rejecting.
So just another way of
saying the same thing.
Now, we're going to jump
right in with a check-in.
And this is a little bit
more, not exactly the material
of the course, but a little bit
more on the philosophical side.
But let's just see
how you do with it.
When you're actually running
a probabilistic machine,
you imagine the
machine, as we're
kind of informally describing
it, is tossing coins.
Every time it has a
non-deterministic--
every time it has a choice.
So it choice tosses a coin
to decide which way to go.
Of course, a real computer
does not have a coin to toss,
presumably.
Well, maybe you might
actually build some hardware
into the machine
that lets it access
randomness in some sense.
Maybe it uses some
quantum mechanical effect
to get some random value
or maybe it uses the timer.
I'm not exactly sure.
You can imagine having a bunch
of ways of implementing that.
A typical way that people
implement randomness
in an algorithm is to use
a pseudo random number
generator, which is a
procedure that might give you
some kind of a value that looks
random, but may not actually
be random.
It's, for example, giving
you the digits of pi.
If you want binary, expressing
pi as a binary number,
then you might calculate the
different successive digits
of pi and use that as for
your random number generator.
Of course, that's a
deterministic procedure,
so it's not really random.
But often, people do use
those kinds of things
when they're simulating
random machines.
So what do you think
about doing that?
Could we use a pseudo
random generator
as the source of randomness
for our randomized algorithm?
Yes, or no, or
what do you think?
So let's launch a poll on
that, so I can see what
your opinion about using
pseudo random number
generators instead of true
randomness for our algorithms.
I'll give you a few seconds,
a minute to weigh in on that.
OK.
We're going to close this down.
Everybody's participated
who wants to?
1, 2, 3.
OK.
Yeah, I think probably the best
answer is A. Let's take a look.
There were a couple of answers
here that, really, that
don't make--
that aren't as good.
I would say, B,
well, usually people
think of pseudo
random generators
as pretty fast procedures.
They're not that
interesting, otherwise.
So I wouldn't say that
B is a good choice
because they're usually
pretty quick to implement.
C is a worse choice, even,
because Turing machines
can do anything that any
other algorithm can do.
So, certainly, if
there is such a thing
as a pseudo random number
generator, and there is,
then you could implement
it on the Turing machine.
D is kind of an
interesting answer
because you're saying, well,
that would imply that P equals
BPP if you could actually
simulate randomness
with a deterministic procedure.
But in fact, the reason
I would not choose D
is because it's
perfectly conceivable
that P does equal BPP.
We don't know that P
is different from BPP,
so it's conceivable
that they're equal.
And in fact, I think if
you polled most complexity
theorists, most
people in my field
would believe that P does equal
BPP just for this very reason,
that if you had sufficiently
good pseudo random number
generators, you could
actually eliminate
the probabalism in these
probabilistic computations.
You could just run them on the
pseudo random number generator.
And in fact, there is
some theory around that
that has been developed.
But at the present
time, we do not
know how to prove that there
were pseudo random number
generators.
And it has some,
actually, there's
actually, in some
line of this research,
has some connection with
the P versus NP problem,
but we don't know how
to prove that there
are sufficiently good pseudo
random number generators that
would allow you to run them
on a probabilistic algorithm
and have a guaranteed behavior
which is as good as running
truly random numbers into
the probabilistic algorithm.
And so the answer
that I would pick
would be A, that you
could use it, sure.
You might get the right answer,
but it's not guaranteed.
We just don't know
how to do the analysis
for the pseudo random
number generators.
And if you had ones
that were good enough,
they would show P
is equal to BPP.
But that might be, in
fact, the correct--
that might actually be true.
OK, so let's continue on.
And remember, now,
branching programs.
We had these kind of
networks of nodes and edges.
And there was a procedure,
we'll see a couple of examples
again, some of the
ones that we had
from before where
you have branching
programs that look like this.
And you have a bunch
of query nodes.
You look at the settings
of the variables
to decide whether to go
down to 0 edge or a 1 edge.
And eventually, you're going
to end up at an output node,
and that's going
to be the output
of the branching program.
And in such a way,
these branching programs
defined Boolean functions,
from the settings of the input
variables to a 0 or 1 output.
Now, you might have
two branching programs
and wonder whether they're
computing the same Boolean
function or not.
And testing that is a
coNP complete problem,
as you're asked to
show on your homework.
Now, if the branching program,
however, has a restriction,
namely, that it's
not allowed to ask
to query the same variable
more than once on a path,
then with that restriction, we
call it a read-once branching
program.
And then, the situation
for testing equivalence
seems to be different.
In fact, we can
give a BPP algorithm
for testing the equivalence of
read-once branching programs,
even though such a
thing is unlikely to be
the case for general branching
programs because of the coNP
completeness.
OK, so I hope you're
comfortable and with me
on all of that reasoning.
OK.
All right.
So the idea for proving this
is, what we're going to do
is we want to take the
two branching programs
and run them on a
randomly-selected input.
But as we observed
last time, if you just
run them on a
randomly-selected Boolean input
where we assign the
variable 0s and 1s,
then that doesn't give
you the right answer
with high probability, because
the two branching programs
might be different, computing
different Boolean functions,
but they differ only on
a single input setting.
And then, just picking
them at random,
you're not going to have a very
high probability of finding
that one place of difference.
So instead, what we're going to
do is define a way to run these
branching programs on
non-Boolean inputs,
where the variables are set
to values other than 0 and 1--
2, 3, 7, 22--
and make sense of that.
And then argue that, by running
the two branching programs
on a randomly-selected
non-Boolean input,
that that's very
high probability
of giving you the right answer.
So somehow, by expanding
the domain of possibilities,
you're going to
better your chance
of getting the right
answer very significantly.
OK.
So even though these
two branching programs
might agree on almost all
of the Boolean inputs,
we're going to show that by
doing this arithmetization--
so this is the method--
if they're really
not equivalent,
they're going to differ
almost all of the time
on the expanded domain.
OK, and then we have the proof.
That's where today's
work is going to be.
OK.
So why don't we
just stop and make
sure we're all together on this?
I can take any questions.
I'll also review how the
arithmetization goes.
But I'll do that next.
So, are we all OK on this?
Good.
So let's move on.
So in order to move
toward understanding
what it means to run
the branching programs
on these non-Boolean
values, we're
going to have to get a
somewhat different perspective
on the computation of
a branching program.
So the standard perspective
is that you take your setting,
your assignment to
the input, which
is 0,1,1 for x1, x2, and x3, and
use that to follow an execution
path through the machine.
So we know x1 is 0,
x2 is 1, x3 is 1,
the output is 1, as I've
indicated in yellow.
This other perspective
says, well, we're
going to operate by labeling the
nodes and edges of the machine.
And that's going to have a
very direct correspondence
with the execution
path perspective.
So we're going to label all of
the nodes and edges on the path
with a 1, as
indicated in yellow,
and all of the nodes
and edges that are not
on the path, all the
other nodes and edges
are going to be labeled 0.
So by following the 1s,
it's like the breadcrumbs
in Hansel and Gretel.
This is the path
you need to follow
to get through the machine.
The 0s are the places
where you don't go.
OK, so the output
label, here, the output
is going to be the label of
the one output node, whatever
you're labeling that.
Because if it's a 1, that
means the path went to the 1,
and if it's a 0, that means
the path didn't go to the 1,
it went to the 0.
So just by looking
at this value,
you can see what the
output of the machine is.
All right.
So let's describe
a different way
of defining this
labeling without just
looking at the path.
Well, it's going to capture
exactly the same thing.
So we're going to say, if
you've already labeled a node,
I'll tell you how to
label the two edges that
emanate from that node.
I'm going to label the one
edge a and the query variable.
Why is that?
Well, a is going to
be either a 0 or 1.
And it's going to
tell us whether or not
the path entered that node.
So if it's a 1, it
entered that node, if 0,
it didn't enter that node.
The only way it's going
to go down this branch
here is if it did
enter the xi node.
If it didn't enter
the xi node, there's
no way it can go
down this branch.
So we're going to
and that value.
So the only way you
can go down this branch
is if it went
through that node--
so that's the a,
the value of a--
and the xi is a 1.
That's why we say a and xi.
So you really have to understand
this little expression here.
If you don't understand
that, you're toast.
OK, so you better understand
this so we can move forward.
I'm happy to take a question.
These are the simplest
questions are sometimes
the most valuable.
If you don't understand why
I'm labeling it this way,
shoot me a chat.
OK.
Now, the other branch,
I'm going to say,
well, I'm only going to go down
this edge if, well, a is true,
so I did go through that node.
And xi is false.
So this is going to be a
and the complement of xi.
All right.
So that's how I'm
going to label these.
This is another way,
giving these expressions
for labeling these edges based
on the label of that node.
And similarly, in order
to complete the picture,
I've got to tell you how
to label the nodes based
on the edges that
are coming into it.
So if I know that I have
a1, a2, and a3, which
tell me the status in terms of
the path of whether the path
went through any of
these edges, well,
I know that it's going
to go to that node
if the or of these values--
if the path went through here,
or it went through there,
or went through there, then
it's going to go to that node.
That's why the or is
the right thing to say.
So this gives me another
way of constructing
the labeling over here without
even talking about paths.
As I describe it,
I argue that it's
going to give the same
result. All right.
So there's a question.
Can we quickly say again why
we can't do that on Boolean?
I'm not sure I
understand the question.
So send it to me again.
Right now, everything
is Boolean.
We haven't done,
arithmetically, anything yet.
And the reason why we can't
just live in the Boolean world
is that, just by taking Boolean
values of Boolean assignments
here, we don't have a
high enough probability
of catching a difference
between the two machines.
All right.
So let's continue.
So now, I'm going
to talk about how
we're going to extend this
to the non-Boolean case,
using the
arithmetization method.
So first of all, arithmetization
is a simulation of and and
or with plus and times,
such that if I think
about true as a 1
and false as a 0,
this is going to give me
a faithful simulation.
It's going to do
the right thing.
It's going to compute exactly
the same values that we expect.
So like a and b, well,
times works just like and.
It does for 1 and 0
as true and false,
times exactly works like and.
And negation is 1 minus.
Or is going to be the
sum minus the product.
And then, these just give
you the right values, a or b.
If you just calculate it
out by plugging in 1s or 0s,
you get the right answer just
by using this arithmetic.
So now, what we're going to do,
instead of using the Boolean
labeling, we'll just use
the arithmetical labeling.
But it's going to compute
exactly the same thing
because the arithmetic
simulates the Boolean.
So we always go
through the start node.
So there's no question about
labeling the very start
node with a 1.
But now, I'm going to
give expressions just
like the Boolean
expressions, but now they're
going to use plus and times
instead of ands and ors.
So let's just see.
Remember what we
did from before.
We had a and xi for this edge.
I'm going to replace that.
What is and?
We just look up
here in our table,
in our translation table.
And becomes times.
So we're going to replace
that with a times xi.
And it's going to
work exactly the same.
But the difference is that
this makes sense even when we
have non-Boolean values.
Times and plus are defined
for non-Boolean values,
whereas ands and or are not.
So what goes down on this edge?
Well, this was a and
the complement of xi,
as you remember.
So that's going to become
a times 1 minus xi.
And then similarly,
we had or over here.
And here's a little
bit of a trick,
but that's going to be
important for the analysis
that we're going to do.
Instead of using the recipe for
or in terms of plus and times,
we're going to have
something a little simpler.
It's just going to be the sum.
And the reason why that works--
good to understand-- is that
because of the acyclic nature
of the branching programs,
at most, one of these edges
can have a path through it.
So this is a kind
of very special
or, sometimes called
the disjoint or.
You're not allowed to have more
than one of the values be 1,
because that never happens when
you have an acyclical graph.
You can never have the path
coming down this way, and then,
again, coming down that way.
Then it would be
entering that node twice.
Have to be a cycle.
So it's going to be
good enough for us,
and necessary for us to
represent this or as a sum.
OK.
So I think that's all I
wanted to say on this slide.
So somebody is asking,
is it possible for some
of these values to be negative?
Yes.
As it stands right now, some of
these values can be negative.
I haven't put any
restriction on what
the values are going to be.
So the input could
be a negative number.
And then, you're going to just
get negative stuff happening.
In fact, there's
subtractions going on here.
So even with positive numbers--
I think we did an
example last time.
I think I'm going to do that
example again of exclusive
or, where you get negative
numbers coming up.
That doesn't matter.
But actually, what we're
going to end up doing
is doing these calculations
modulo some prime number q.
OK.
I'm going to pick
some prime like 17,
and do all the
calculations mod 17.
And the reason for
doing it that way
is really because we're going
to be picking random assignments
to the variables as our input.
And it makes the most
sense to do that when
you have a finite set of
possibilities to pick them up.
So we're not going to pick
like a random integer.
There's infinitely
many possibilities.
And yeah, you could set
up a distribution there,
but that's very complicated.
That actually might work.
I'm not sure.
I haven't actually gone
through that analysis.
But the typical
way people do this
is by looking at what's
called a finite field.
So I'll talk about
that in a second.
Why is there at most one
1 among a1, a2, and a3?
The 1s-- I'll say once
again-- but the 1s correspond
to the path.
So this is a 1 if the
path went this way.
Just think about it.
The path cannot go through
a1 and can, at the same time,
go through a2, because that
means the path went through
this node.
Then, how is it going
to get over to a2?
It's going to go
through that node twice.
In an acyclic graph, you cannot
have a path going through
it's the same node
more than once.
So you're going to have
to think about that.
OK, let's move on.
So now we're going to
talk about the same--
we're going to look at that
non-Boolean labeling applied
to an example.
So here is a very
simple branching program
that actually
computes the exclusive
or function in
the Boolean world.
So this is the
labeling that I just
developed for you, the
arithmetical labeling.
And we always label
the start node with 1,
because the path always
goes through there.
And now, let's look at this
before we jump ahead, let's
look at this edge here.
Remember what it is.
We have to apply this rule here.
This is the one edge
coming out of a node that
already is labeled.
So it's that label on
that node times the xi.
Because if you're thinking
about it, that, that's the and,
captures the and.
So it's just a times xi.
So it's x1, in this case.
So x1 is a 2 in our input.
So it's going to be
1, which is the a,
times the x1, which is 2.
So this edge gets labeled 2.
Now this-- well, OK, let's
look at this edge now.
I think that's next.
This is the 1 minus xi,
it's the 1 minus x1.
So it's 1 minus 2.
So you're going to
end up with a minus 1.
1 minus times minus 2.
1 times 1 minus 2, which is
minus 1, so it's a minus 1.
Now we're going to label these
two nodes using the other rule.
So this gets a 2 because that's
a sum of the incoming edges.
This gets a minus
1, because that's
the sum of its incoming edges.
And now we're going to look at--
which order did I do this in?
OK, I'm going to
do this edge now.
0 edge, which is going to be
2 times 1 minus its variable.
So it's 1 minus x2.
X2 is a 3.
So it's 1 minus 3 to minus 2.
So 2 times minus 2 is minus 4.
OK, I don't want to
rush through this.
No point in just blabbering on.
I'm just trying to work this
example so you get the idea.
OK, so could you fill this
next one out yourself?
So this is the one outgoing
edge from this x2 node.
So x2 is labeled with 2 here.
So there's a is 2.
This is the one edge going out,
so it's one on this side here.
So it's 2 times the x2. x2
is a 3, so it's 2 times 3.
So this should be 6.
Oops.
Right here-- 6.
I'm going to do the same thing.
So x2 is labeled minus 1.
So minus 1 times 1 minus.
So you get a 2 here,
you get a minus 3 here,
just following, again,
the same process.
And now, what is the
label on this 0 node here?
So again, you take the sum
of its incoming labels.
So there was a 2 and a 6.
So that's an 8.
And this is a a minus 3
and a minus 4 coming in.
So it's a minus 7.
What's the output?
The output is minus 7, because
that's the label on the 1 node.
OK, output is minus 7.
OK.
So this is going to
be our way of defining
the output of a
branching program when
it has a non-Boolean
setting on its inputs.
If you had the Boolean
setting on its inputs
and you followed this procedure,
what would you get out?
You would get the
same answer that you
would get by following
the path because
the arithmetical simulation
is a faithful simulation
of the ands and ors.
And the ands and
ors capture exactly
when-- what the path does.
So this is a strict
extension of the operation
of the branching program
into a new realm,
these non-Boolean values.
On the old realm, it behaves
just as it did originally.
And that's critical
to understand that.
Yeah, somebody's asking what
the final value of the 0s,
they'd also be the same.
Sure.
In the Boolean case, if we
follow this in the Boolean
cases, all of the labels would
be exactly what they were.
They would just be the 0s and
1s that we had from before.
So does this exactly mimic x
or if you take this all mod 2?
I don't know.
I'd have to think about that.
I don't think that
that's essential.
In this case, it
might behave correctly
if you take the
answer mod 2 for XOR.
But the XOR is going
to be very special.
And I'm not sure.
That might happen to be true.
I'd have to think
about it for a second,
but I'm not sure
that's relevant.
OK, so this is a good question.
If I picked a different
branching program that also
implements XOR-- or--
so it would be an equivalent
branching program--
would it behave the same way
on the non-Boolean values?
And the answer to
that is yes and no.
You understand the question?
It's a very good question.
And actually, we're going to
prove this in the analysis.
It's going to be easy to
prove because I gave you
both possibilities, yes and no.
But let me tell you
what I mean by that.
So you understand the question.
Suppose I had a different
branching program.
I'm not sure you can come up
with a different branching
program, but let's
say you could.
You have a different
branching program, yeah, sure
you can come--
you can do the variables in a
different order, for example.
So suppose you come up with
a different branching program
that gives you XOR.
And now you plugged in 2 and 3.
Would I always get
the same value out?
Yes, if that other branching
program was read-once.
No, not necessarily
if it's not read-once.
And that's why
read-once is critical.
As we will prove, for two
read-once branching programs,
if they behave the same
way on the Boolean values,
they behave the same way even
on the non-Boolean values.
That's not necessarily true if
the branching programs are not
read-once.
OK, we will see that.
We will prove that and use that.
That's going to be important.
OK, so here is the
algorithm sketch,
which is kind of a little
bit even sort of suggested
by that very good question.
So what we're going
to do is we want
to take the two branching
programs that we're trying
to test if they're equivalent.
We're going to pick a random
non-Boolean input assignment--
so set the values here
chosen from the field,
but we'll get there.
A random value for x1, random
value for x2, and so on.
These could be numbers like
17, and 25, and 23, and so on.
And then, using this process,
run the branching programs
to evaluate them on that
non-Boolean assignment.
If they disagree,
then we're going
to know that the two branching
programs were not equivalent,
even on the non-Boolean case.
Even on the Boolean case.
Did I say that wrong?
So if they disagree, even
on the non-Boolean case,
they have to be an equivalent
even in the Boolean case.
Not obvious.
But if they agree, then
it's not a guarantee
that they're
equivalent, but it's
going to be very strong evidence
that they're equivalent.
OK, so that's where the
probabilistic nature
is going to come in.
So we're going to prove that.
So first, we have to
develop an algebraic fact.
And that involves polynomials.
This is a simple thing
that I think many of you
have run into already,
perhaps even in high school.
I'm not going to prove
the algebraic facts,
but I'm going to state them.
And actually, the
proofs are not hard.
They're in the textbook.
So suppose we have a
polynomial of degree d here.
It happens to have p.
So there's a bunch of constants.
These a's are constants.
x is the variable
of the polynomial.
And I presume you've seen
polynomials written out
like this.
And so if you assign x to some
value, some constant value z,
and the polynomial
evaluates to 0,
we often call that a
root of the polynomial.
So these are the places where
the polynomial evaluates to 0
that I've of shown over here.
Those are the roots.
It's not hard to show that a
low-degree polynomial cannot
have lots of roots.
Basically, if the polynomial
has degree at most d,
it can have at most d roots,
as long as the polynomial
itself is not the
everywhere 0 polynomial,
because obviously, then
everything is a root.
Oops, typo.
Thank you.
Should be d minus 2 over there.
Pretend that's a 2.
All right, so if we have
a low-degree polynomial--
let's not get
ahead of ourselves.
If we have a
low-degree polynomial,
a polynomial of degree at most
d, it has at most d roots.
And that's a simple proof.
The basic idea is
every time you have
a-- if you have a root
of the polynomial,
so if setting x equal to 5 gives
you a root of the polynomial,
it's a 0 of the polynomial,
then x-- you can easily to see
that x minus 5 is a
factor of the polynomial.
You can divide by x minus 5,
and you get a new polynomial
of degree one less.
And you can just, which
is going by induction,
has one fewer root.
So you can just divide out
by the roots, basically.
It's very straightforward.
And other very important thing--
if I have two polynomials
that are both low-degree,
they cannot agree
on very many places.
That follows from what
I just proved above.
Because what I'll do is I
take those two polynomials,
and they look at the
difference, which is also
a low-degree polynomial.
Every time there's an
agreement between those two
original polynomials,
there's a zero
of the difference polynomial.
And because that difference
polynomial cannot have too many
zeroes, the two original
polynomials cannot have too
many agreements.
So the corollary is that if
x and y are both polynomials
of degree at most d, and
they're not the same polynomial,
because then the difference
would be the 0 polynomial,
then the number of places where
they're equal is at most d.
So the proof is
just letting p be
the difference of p1 and p2--
very standard kind of a trick.
Now the above is going
to hold for any field.
A field is just a set
with plus and times
with the familiar properties
of distributive law and so on
and identities and
all the stuff that you
would expect plus and times
to have in the normal world.
And so we're going to talk
about the finite field that
has only q elements--
that has exactly q elements,
where q is a prime number.
So it turns out that-- and I'm
not going to prove all this,
but it's pretty simple stuff--
that if you just take the
numbers from 1 to q minus 1--
from 0 to q minus 1, and
use plus n times mod q,
that has all the right
properties to be a field.
So just think of it--
just modular arithmetic,
mod some prime q.
And then we can in a natural
way pick a random assignment
to a variable from the field
because it's just choosing
from among q possibilities.
Yeah, so getting
a question here.
The coefficients of the
polynomial and the assignment
to the variables-- they're all
going to come from this field.
So everything's going to
be operating in this field.
Don't let that throw you off.
Just your ordinary intuition
about the way arithmetic works
is going to be just fine.
But this is important here from
the perspective of thinking
about this probabilistically.
So I'm going to rethink about
this polynomial lemma, which
says there are not
too many roots.
In terms of the
probability of picking
an element of the field,
what are the chances
that it happens to be a root?
So if you have a
low-degree polynomial,
and you pick a random
value in the field,
what's the probability
that you've got a root?
Well, it's just the
number of roots divided
by the size of the field.
So if you have this
really big field,
and you have this
low-degree polynomial,
it's going to be pretty
unlikely that you're
going to end up picking one of
the zeroes, one of the roots,
just at random.
That's all that this is saying.
So there's at most d roots
out of the q possibilities.
And the last thing I'm
going to introduce here
is the multivariable
version of this
which is called, perhaps
somewhat unfairly,
but it's called the
Schwartz-Zippel lemma,
though in various forms, it had
been known prior to their work.
In some cases, the literature
actually goes back a long ways.
But anyway, this is called
the Schwartz-Zippel lemma.
Doesn't really matter,
except to the people whose
credit is being denied.
But that's not one of us.
So anyway, the Schwartz-Zippel
lemma says that if you have now
a polynomial in
several variables,
which is not the 0 polynomial,
where each variable has low
degree--
so if I say if it has
degree at most d in each xi.
So each variable is going to
have at most an exponent of d
appearing in that polynomial.
And now if we pick random values
to assign to all of those n
variables from the
field, the probability
that we ended up with a root,
that we ended up with a 0,
is something you can bound.
So it's m times d, so
the number of variables
times this maximum
degree, divided
by the size of the field.
And this is going to
come up later for us.
And this is another fairly
simple proof, a little bit more
sophisticated than the
one that we had above.
And in fact, it uses that one as
a lemma to prove this theorem.
So we're going to--
not going to prove any of that,
but I refer you to the book
if you're curious.
Yeah, so a couple of
good questions here.
What happens if these values
are bigger than q, for example?
Then it's not
telling you anything.
If d is bigger than
q, m is bigger than q,
or the product is bigger than
q, then you learn nothing
from this lemma--
from this theorem.
So typically in applications,
you're going to pick a large--
you're going to have
the flexibility.
You get to choose q to be
something that you want.
So we're going to pick
the field to be big
enough so that the m and d are
going to be relatively small.
In fact, d is going to end
up being 1, as we will see.
And m is the number
of variables.
So we're going to
pick q, which is
going to be substantially larger
than the number of variables.
And how is the degree defined
in multivariable polynomials?
If the polynomial has xy squared
plus 3x to the 5th y squared z,
you just pull out each
variable separately.
And you look at the maximum
degree of that variable.
So the x in that case had
had a degree 5 appearance.
The y had a degree 2 appearance.
So you take the maximum
over all of the variables
of the degree of that variable.
And that's going to be
the bound on the degree
of the polynomial.
So in fact, in our case,
d is going to be 1.
So all of the
variables-- there's
not going to be any
exponents on anything.
Everything is going
to be exponent 1.
Is q related to the number
we choose for the mod?
Yeah, q is the number
we're choosing for the mod.
We're doing everything mod q.
So all the arithmetic is
going to operate in mod q,
and that's the size of the
field that we're going to pick.
So I think we're
here at the break.
Happy to take some
more questions,
but why don't we
just start that off.
And I will see you
in five minutes.
But in the meantime, happy
to shoot me questions.
So what happens if we use
Boolean assignments in the XOR
example?
Would that work to be
able to check agreement?
It would.
So it's hard to make an argument
based on just a single example.
I think the better
thing would be
to look at two
branching programs that
just differ in a single place.
So I can even suggest two.
You can make a branching program
that always outputs true.
It doesn't even
read its variables.
Or if it reads them, they
always go to the same place.
And it ends up always
at the q output.
So you imagine a
branching program
that always outputs
1, no matter what
the assignments to
the variables are.
And you can easily
make such a thing.
And then you make
another branching program
that computes the or function.
So it reads every variable.
And it's going to be 1 if
any one of those variables
is set to 1.
So the only time
the or function is
0 is if everything is set to 0.
But now if you're
trying to randomly check
whether the always one function
is equal to the or function--
of course, without knowing
in advance what they are,
because that's cheating.
You're just given
these two functions,
and you want to know-- these
two branching programs.
And you want to know,
are they computing
the same thing or not?
And by this procedure
of randomly sampling,
you're always going to get
these branching programs both
to say 1, unless you just happen
to pick the random assignment
of everything set to 0.
And that's very unlikely that
you're going to pick that.
If you imagine you have--
your branching program
has 100 variables in it.
It's only 2 to the
minus 100 chance
that you're going to set
them all to 0 randomly.
And so you're extremely
unlikely to find
that one place of difference
if there's only a single place.
If there's lots of
places of difference,
then it's not so bad.
But if the number, the fraction
of differences, is low,
you're going to have
to do a lot of samples
in order to find that--
possibly exponentially
many samples.
And then you won't run
in polynomial time.
So let me just see if
there's other questions here.
Why can we accept--
going back to the
Boolean labeling
side, why can we accept that
b1 equals b2 if b1 and b2
agree on--
only on just one
input assignment?
No, we didn't say that.
All right, I'll go back there.
Boolean assignment-- is this--
I'm not sure which one you mean.
Is this the one you mean?
I don't know--
Boolean labeling,
so it must be it.
Why do we non-Boolean labeling?
No, I see what you're saying.
You're saying about this here.
We're just going to pick
one random assignment.
And if they agree on
that one random case,
then we will say accept,
because you might think,
well, we should take a
whole bunch of samples.
That's a good question.
But in fact, we're going to
arrange the probability such
that if the two things
are not equivalent, then
it's going to be--
the values will be
different almost everywhere,
or a large number of places.
So just picking one
and having them agree
is going to be strong enough
evidence that you're still
going to accept.
And you'll have still
a low probability
of getting an error.
You'd have to see the analysis.
Are we assuming the roots of
the polynomials are integers?
No, we're operating
over a field here.
Even talking about integers
doesn't totally make sense.
But it doesn't really matter.
We're not assuming that.
Oh, I should have
taken this away.
The bound still works.
The bound still works even
if we have non-integers.
I'm not sure if I'm
being helpful here.
Why don't we just move on?
But we're not
assuming that these
are integers because the
bound doesn't matter.
If it says there is at most
five roots, including the reals,
there's still going to be five
roots, including the integers.
All right, so let's continue.
Good, all right.
So now everybody's back, I hope?
Let's talk about
moving forward here.
Where we're going
with this is we
want to analyze the
algorithm, which
picks a random non-Boolean
input and evaluates the two
branching programs.
And in order to do that, we're
going to look a little bit more
carefully at what happens
when we arithmetize
the branching
program, and we run it
on these non-Boolean values.
And so what I'm going to do is
take this branching program.
Let's say this is the
same XOR, exclusive
or, branching program.
But instead of labeling it as
we did before by setting x1
to 2 and x2 to 3, I'm going
to leave x1 and x2 variables
and just do a
symbolic execution.
So I'm going to label
these things, just
leaving x1 and x2 as variables.
So let's just see what
we get if we do that.
So remember, we
assigned this to be 1.
Now this edge here is--
here's the rule.
It's a, which is 1, times x1.
So this should be--
without knowing what
the value of x1 is,
leaving it as a
variable, we're just
going to put down x1 over here.
Over here, what goes over there?
Well, it's 1 times 1 minus x1--
just 1 minus x1.
Now we're going to add
things up, as we did before.
And now what happens,
for example--
I think I have this
edge coming next.
Let's look at this edge,
the one edge coming out.
The label now is
x1 on this node.
This is the one edge
coming out, so you
multiply by the value of x2.
We're leaving it as a
variable, so we're just
going to multiply it by x2.
And so we're just going
to get x1 times x2--
x1x2 on this edge.
And now what happens
on this edge?
So this x1 times--
think with me--
times 1 minus x2.
And similarly over here, we
have 1 minus x1 on this node.
So I think on the one edge
coming out, it's 1 minus x1,
now times x2, because
that's this rule again.
1 minus x, 1 times x2.
And this is going to be 1
minus x1 times 1 minus x2.
Now we're going to add
this up for the 0 node.
So we have this value, 1 minus
x1, 1 minus x2, plus x1 x2.
And on this note
here, we're going
to add these two values up.
So 1 minus x1 times x2
plus x1 times 1 minus x2.
And that's the output, now
expressed symbolically.
Now you could plug
things in, and you're
going to get the same value
out as you did before.
But let's leave it as
a polynomial for now
because that's going to
help us and analyze this.
So now, notice the
form of this polynomial
is something special.
What happens is
it's going to look
like a bunch of products of
xi's and 1 minus xi's added up.
So it's a sum of
products of that form.
So each row here is a product
of xi's and 1 minus xi's.
And then those rows
are all added together.
I claim that's going to be
the form of this polynomial.
You see this already
has that form.
And the reason for that is
every time you go to a node,
you're just adding things up.
So that's just going to be
like adding up more rows.
And every time you go
down to through an edge,
you're multiplying what
you have so far either
by an xi or a 1 minus xi.
So you're just accumulating
products of xi's and 1 minus
xi's, and you're
just adding them up.
So this is what that polynomial
is going to look like.
Now let's look a little bit more
carefully at the form of this.
So for one thing, could we
have higher powers here,
like x2 cubed?
Could that happen?
And when I say it's products
of the xi's and 1 minus xi's,
maybe there's going to be some
xi's that appear several times
in the product.
Well, that cannot happen.
Why?
It's a read once
branching program.
So every time you multiply
by an xi or a 1 minus xi,
you're never going
to do that again,
because doing that would
imply you're querying
that variable more than once.
So this can't happen.
So I cross that out.
This just appeared.
It's off to the side, here.
But yeah, I'm crossing that out.
That does not happen.
Another thing that is
part of-- that's worthy--
that's going to be helpful to
notice about this polynomial--
and by the way, maybe
I'm being confusing here.
This I'm supposed to be
representing as a generic form
of the polynomial.
This is not some
particularly-- yeah,
I should have said
this at the beginning.
This is not some
particular polynomial
that came from anything.
I'm just trying to describe
what the general form
of the polynomial looks like,
just as an illustration.
So this polynomial's
1 minus x1 times
x2 times 1 minus x3
times x4 and so on,
and adding up a bunch
of rows like this.
I'm just saying this is
what the polynomial will
look like for maybe
some branching program.
So every branching
program is either
going to have some polynomial
that looks sort of like this.
And what I'm also going to say--
for convenience,
now, I want to say
that each row is going to have
every single variable appear
either as an xi or
as a 1 minus xi.
So in order to get
that, I need to make
a further minor assumption
about the branching program--
that it's a read exactly once.
Currently when I
say "read once,"
it can avoid reading some
variables on some branches,
because it's like a
read at most once.
But now I want to say that every
variable gets read exactly one
time on every branch.
And what that's going to
mean is that every row
is going to contain every
variable, either as an xi
or as a 1 minus xi.
We can eliminate that
extra assumption easily.
And I'm going to leave
that as an exercise to you.
It's not very hard to do.
So I think if you
follow me, you can see--
and you play with it
for a minute or two,
you'll see that it
doesn't really matter.
But I think just for the
first time through this,
let's assume that every
row has every variable--
so important to understand.
So this is the output polynomial
of this branching program.
So let's look furthermore
at this polynomial
and understand the rows.
Let's take one row
out of this polynomial
to understand what
it represents.
So one row here--
it's a product of a
bunch of things, product
of a bunch of variables,
either variables
or 1 minus the variables.
Let's think about this in the
Boolean setting, first of all.
So in the Boolean setting, each
of these variables are going
to be 0's and 1's.
And the 1 minus the variables
are also going to be
0's and 1's.
So it's going to be a
product of 0's and 1's.
If there's a 0 that
appears in that product,
that product is going to be a
0, because 0 times anything is
a 0.
So the only way that product
cannot be 0 is if all of those
values are 1's in
the Boolean case.
So that means that x1--
well, let's look
at the second row.
So x1 had to be a 1. x2 had
to be a 1. x3 had to be a 1.
x4 had to be a 0 in
order to continue
the product of 1's, and so on.
So in fact, there's only a
single Boolean assignment
to these variables
which make that row 1.
Every other assignment to those
variables makes that row 0.
Saying that another
way, each of these rows
corresponds to one of
the rows of the truth
table for the Boolean function,
where the truth table is true,
gives a true value,
gives a 1 value
for the function on that row.
So I hope you're all familiar
with the notion of a truth
table of a Boolean function.
You just write down
the Boolean function,
every possible assignment
to the Boolean function,
and you write down 1 or
0 or true or false for
what the value of
that function is.
It's just a tabular
representation
of the Boolean function.
It's called a truth table.
This thing here gives
you all of the 1's--
all of the rows that are 1
in that Boolean function.
That's what this
polynomial gives you.
So I think we're at a
pause point for this slide.
It's deathly silent on the chat.
So I have a feeling that
that went down rough for you.
It's important to understand the
form of this polynomial here.
It corresponds to the truth
table of the Boolean function.
So each one of these rows
is only going to be--
again, thinking Boolean
now, each one of these rows
is only going to be 1
on an assignment which
makes the function 1--
one of the assignments
that makes the function 1.
And somebody says, and similarly
for the expression for the 0
node.
Yeah, the 0 node, which
I'm not focusing on, but,
yeah, the 0 node would be all
of the false rows of the truth
table.
But the 1 node, the
polynomial for the 1 node,
are all of the true rows--
correspond to all
of the true rows
in the function of the
branching-- the function
that branching program computes.
Let me just tell you
where we're going.
Is it possible to have two
rows that are the same?
If you think about how the
rows are being produced, no.
You can't have two
rows that are going
to be the same,
because for one thing,
you have to think about what
this looks like in the Boolean
case.
If you have two
rows are the same,
that means this thing is going
to-- would have an output which
is non-Boolean because
you're going to end up
with a 2 coming out that way
by adding those rows together.
That can never happen.
And if you just look at
the way it's constructed,
you're never going to--
because every time you have
a branching, one way is an xi.
The other one is 1 minus xi.
So every time you're
branching there,
every time there's a
node, they're different.
So you're never going
to have two rows that
are going to be the same.
But let me tell you the
importance of connecting up
this polynomial with
the truth table,
because that tells us that if
the two functions of the two
branching programs that
we started off with
agree in their Boolean values,
then the two polynomials are
going to be the same.
Because if the two branching
programs have the same Boolean
function, so they're equivalent,
then the truth tables
will be the same.
And therefore, these
polynomials will be the same.
And therefore, they
will behave the same way
on all non-Boolean
values, because they're
the same polynomial.
So I'm getting ahead
of myself, but that's
what we're going to argue.
That's why it's
important to understand
the connection with
the truth table,
because it builds on the--
understanding something
about how this thing behaves
in the Boolean case
is going to give us
information about how it
behaves in the non-Boolean case.
But let's continue here, then.
Yeah, this is essentially
the last slide,
but we're going to spend
some time on this one.
So here's the algorithm.
We are going to take our
two branching programs.
The variables are x1 to xm.
First of all,
we're going to find
a prime which is
at least 3 times m,
the number of variables.
m is not a very big number.
It's just the
number of variables.
So finding a prime that's bigger
than that is straightforward.
We're not talking
about huge primes here.
We're talking about very
modest-sized primes.
Even trial and error is
going to be good enough.
Now that's going to be
the size of the field.
It's going to be
a field of size q.
And now we're going to pick
a non-Boolean assignment
to the variables.
We're going to pick a
non-Boolean assignment
to the variables and evaluate
the two branching programs
on that non-Boolean assignment
using the arithmetization.
If they agree,
then we'll accept.
If they don't agree, then
we're going to reject.
Now we have to argue
that this works.
So we're going to first of
all arithmetize these two
branching programs,
and we're going
to get these two polynomials.
They each have the form that--
as I described, so a bunch
of rows that correspond to
the truth tables of those two
respective branching programs.
First claim-- that if the
branching programs were
equivalent, so they compute
the same Boolean function,
then the two polynomials
agree everywhere.
So then the two
branching programs
are going to get the same
value on every non-Boolean case
as well as on the Boolean cases.
So they agree in the Boolean.
That means they always agree,
even on the non-Boolean.
And I kind of
argued that already.
The other point is that if the
two branching programs are not
equivalent, so they differ
at some Boolean value,
now picking a random value
for the polynomial evaluation,
you're going to have only a
1/3 chance that they're going
to agree, so a small chance.
All right, so now let's
prove these two facts.
The first one I
already kind of argued.
If the two branching
programs agree
on all the Boolean values,
then their functions
have the same truth table.
So then the polynomials
are identical
because the polynomials
correspond to the truth table.
And so therefore, they
always agree, even
on the non-Boolean values.
So that means that
the probability
that if you evaluate the two
polynomials on a random place,
whether they'll be equal, that's
a certainty, because in fact,
in this case, p1 and p2
are the same polynomial.
Now for two, if the branching
programs differ somewhere,
even in one place, well you
know the polynomials could not
be the same.
They have to be
different polynomials
because the polynomials include
the behavior in the Boolean
case as well as all
the rest of the field.
So the polynomials
have to be the same.
And now we're going to apply
the Schwartz-Zippel lemma.
We have two different
polynomials.
They can only agree in a
relatively small number
of places.
So that says that, from the
Schwartz-Zippel theorem,
then the probability
that p1 and p2 agree
at this random location
is at most this value
that we had from
before, the degree
times the number of
variables divided
by the size of the field.
The degree is 1.
And the field is
at least 3 times
the number of variables in size.
So that means you get
this inequality here.
And so therefore, the
probability is a 1/3--
at most 1/3.
And that's good enough.
This is the probability that
you get the wrong answer is
going to be at most 1/3.
So you're going to
get the right answer
with at least 2/3 probability.
So even just doing a
single sample point
is going to be enough to
give it a PPP algorithm.
What I have are a couple of
check-ins here now for you.
Whoops, somehow this-- going
to take me out of here.
All right, so this
is a little hard,
but let's see how you do on it.
Suppose the branching
program is--
well, maybe I a little bit
discussed this already,
but that's OK.
The branching programs
were not read once.
The polynomials might have
exponents bigger than 1.
So where would the proof fail?
Would they fail at the point
where b1 and equivalent to b2
implies that they agree
on all Boolean inputs?
So that's the first step here.
Or was it that agreeing
on all Boolean inputs
implies that the
polynomials are the same?
Or would it be that having the
two polynomials being equal
implies that they always agree?
So those are the three steps
in the proof of part one.
So let's see.
What do you think there?
I'm getting a
couple of questions
about picking the prime number.
The prime number here is--
this is a very
small prime number.
You could even represent
that prime number in unary
within the amount of time we
have, because don't forget,
this is a prime number
whose magnitude is at most
the number of variables.
So you can write that
prime number in unary.
And finding the prime
and testing primality,
testing whether the
number is prime,
is something that
you can do even
with a brute-force algorithm,
and it would be good enough.
You don't have to do anything
fancy about testing primality
in this case.
So why does it have to be prime?
You need it to prime in
order for it to be a field.
So this is just
the algebra part.
If you did not have
a prime number,
then some of the field
properties don't work.
And you may no
longer get the fact
that the polynomial has
a small number of roots.
So that's all I
can say about that.
Is the polynomial
like a hash function
for the branching program?
Are they equal if
they are the same,
but sometimes the
value is also equal
if the programs are different?
That's an interesting idea.
Is the polynomial acting
like a hash function?
I think there is something
to what you're saying,
but I think it's actually
in the other direction.
It's related to a hash function,
but it's actually acting more
like an error-correcting code.
Let's save that for later.
It's a very good point.
It's a very good question.
Maybe we can talk about
it after if you remind me.
OK, let's end this poll here.
Should C be-- if
having these two agree
implies-- well, I mean,
the question is, should we
change p1 and p2 always agree
to b1 and b2 always agree?
Well, b1 and b2 are
behaving exactly the way p1
and p2 behave, so I'm not
sure it really matters.
Too much time on this
chat, on this poll here.
Let's end this poll--
oh, sharing results.
Yeah, so the
correct answer is B,
that agreeing on
all Boolean inputs
implies that they are equal.
The other two
follow immediately.
They're still true.
But if it's not read
once, even though they
agree on all the Boolean
inputs, they won't necessarily
agree as polynomials.
For one thing, if you just take
the two polynomials x1 squared
and x1, they agree on
all the Boolean inputs,
but they're not the same.
They agree in the Boolean
world, because 0 squared is 0,
and 1 squared is 1.
But they're not the
same polynomial.
Let's move on.
Actually, I have
another check-in
on the same slide here.
And this is actually
answering a question
that I got in the chat.
If p1 and p2 were--
how big are these polynomials?
These look like
they could be big.
If they're exponentially
large, would that
be a problem for
the time complexity?
So pick A or B here.
We're running out of time here.
So why don't I not say too much
and just let you go with it.
I'm going to close this down.
All in?
Well, oh, my god, by one point.
This is like Georgia here--
do a recount.
In fact, B is correct by a hair.
They are not polynomial in size.
The truth tables
can be very large.
As we did with the
branching program
for the exclusive or
case, you don't actually
write down the polynomials
to evaluate them.
You can evaluate them
as you're going along.
The polynomials are huge.
But you don't have to
write down the polynomials
to evaluate them.
That's only part of the proof.
The algorithm doesn't have
to deal with the polynomials
itself, so maybe good
to think about this.
And somebody says, did
I invent this proof?
No, I did not invent this proof.
It's a wonderful proof,
but it's not mine.
I would love to have been--
get to take the credit for it.
So why don't we wrap this up?
Is there some way to
simplify the polynomials
as we're going along
so that we don't end up
with them being too big and
so that we can then just
look at the polynomials?
Not that I know of.
I think the polynomials
are really going to be big.
And so there's not going to be
any way to view it just as--
if you could, it
would be fantastic,
because that would give you
a deterministic algorithm.
I think the only
way that people know
how to do this in
terms of random inputs
to a polynomial, which
is too big to write down.
If you could write it down and
just analyze the polynomials,
you'd have a huge,
huge result there.
Oh, I'm glad people
like this proof.
That's good.
How many actual quantities
are there in the formula?
I'm not sure what that means.
What formula?
I mean, the polynomial is huge.
The number of
different polynomials--
well, I guess I don't
understand the question.
What motivates the idea
of arithmetization?
What would make
somebody think of this?
I'm not sure, actually.
But we're going to use it
even in a more remarkable way
in the last two lectures of
the course, so stay tuned.
I mean, this is sort of clever,
but seems very specialized.
But the next part, where we
go to the next application,
we're going to use this
to analyze satisfiability,
which is a much more
general kind of a situation.
And that, I think, is
especially remarkable.
For the polynomials p1 and p2,
it's only a polynomial number--
I don't think so, because--
well, it depends on
the size of the field.
The size of-- no, it's
going to be something
like m to the mth power, right?
So those are the number
of possible inputs.
Each field element has 3m
possibilities, roughly.
And there are m field
elements, so it's
m to the 3m different
possible inputs
that you're picking at random.
So anyway, I'm going to
shut this down and move over
to the office hours Zoom.
Feel free to join me there.
Otherwise, I will see
you all on Thursday.
Take care.